le raquette des impôts je dire je faire
ça c'est pas une parabole c'est du
physique je prend un billet de 500
ball je dire je suis taxé
[Musique]
à4% je vous dire ce qu' me
reste c'est bien c'est illégal ce que je
va faire
égalil je vais vous dire ce
reste j'arrêterai à 74
% il faut quand même pas déconner parce
que ça c'est pas pour les pauvres hein
c'est pour le nucléaire et tout vous
rendez compte que vous provoquez
beaucoup de monde en faisant ça écoutez
c'est mon
Ponant ce qu' reste sur 500 et ça ça
veut dire maison au Quartier Latin
voyage quand vous le voulez et puis plus
maintenant non qu'est-ce qu' est foutu
vous pouvez plus travailler comme
autrefois j'aimerais que les pauvres
tous des roll